on nous a imposé un programme sur les
compétences à fonctionne pas peut-on
avoir notre - plus de 13000
participation en ligne 1000 personnes
qui ont pris part aux rencontres
régionales 300 mémoires de déposer le
ministre de l'éducation est en
consultation partout dans la province
depuis octobre sur la réussite éducative
et tout le monde peut se prononcer il ya
de l'engouement mais c'est le signe
aussi qui a des préoccupations eu un
échec
moi je dirais plutôt que on a établi
plein priorités comme société on a pris
pour acquis celle de l'éducation sujet
récurrent pendant cette consultation la
valorisation des enseignants certains
souhaitent plus de liberté pour sortir
du cadre imposé par l'état pour d'autres
et bien ça passe par un ordre
professionnel
la valorisation doit passer par
l'autonomie professionnelle on est les
on est les experts on est les meilleurs
prix lumières personnes placées pour
appliquer des approches choisir limite
on peut pas généraliser
je me sentirais inconfortable d'avoir
une liberté totale professionnelle sans
avoir à rendre de compte à mes
concitoyens
thies - la maison le pian 2 av je pense
montage paul coll je passe mon temps
diront jamais tu es ton professeur le
bio peut-être pas raison ben je ne
participe pas à cette valorisation de
cette consultation mènera à une
politique sur la réussite éducative
déposé au printemps mais il est encore
temps de vous prononcer si vous le
voulez sur le site web du ministère
d'éducation